Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. At the head of the terrace and portico successively is a garden suite of rooms, my favourite spot and well worthy of being so. I had them built myself. In this is a sunny chamber
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。若要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistory.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。在露台和柱廊的正前方，是一套花园间的客房，这是我最喜欢的地方，也完全当得起这份喜爱。它们是我亲手建的。这里有一间阳光充足的房间
which commands the terrace on one side, the sea on another, and the sun on both, besides an apartment which looks on the portico through folded doors, and on the sea through a window. In the middle of the wall is a neat recess. It holds a couch and two easy chairs, and as you lie on the couch, you have the sea at your feet, the villa at your back, and the woods at your head head and all these views may be looked at separately from each window or blended into one prospect adjoining is a chamber for passing the night or taking a nap and unless the windows are open you do not hear a sound either of your slaves talking or the murmur of the sea or the raging of the storms nor do you see the flashes of the lightning or know that it is day. So that, Tom Holland, was Pliny the Younger on his Laurentine villa west of Rome in the early second century AD. It sounds absolutely idyllic. It sounds exactly the kind of place I like to stay
一面朝向露台，一面朝向大海，两面都能晒到太阳，此外还有一个房间，通过折叠门可以望见柱廊，通过窗户可以望见大海。墙壁正中有一个精致的壁龛。里面放着一张长椅和两把单人沙发；躺在长椅上，你脚下是大海，身后是别墅，头上是树林——所有这些景色都可以从各个窗户单独欣赏，也可以融合成一幅完整的全景。紧邻着的是一间用来过夜或小憩的房间，除非窗户开着，否则你听不到一点奴隶们的交谈声、海浪的呢喃声，或是风暴的咆哮声，你也看不到闪电的闪光，甚至感觉不到天亮。汤姆·霍兰，以上就是小普林尼在公元二世纪初对他在罗马以西的劳伦提亚姆别墅的描述。听起来简直像世外桃源。听起来正是我喜欢的那种地方
in on holiday. So this is what? This is Pliny's holiday home. Is that right, Tom? Kind of. I mean, Pliny is fabulously rich. He obviously has a house in Rome. He has another house in Tuscany. He has another house up by Lake Como. So like, what's his name? George Clooney. Does he advertise Nespresso? I don't think he did.
度假时住。所以这是什么？这是普林尼的度假屋，对吗，汤姆？算是吧。我是说，普林尼极其富有。他在罗马显然有栋房子。他在托斯卡纳还有另一栋房子。他在科莫湖边还有一栋房子。所以就像，那叫什么来着？乔治·克鲁尼。他是不是做过奈斯派索的广告？我觉得他没做过。
That would have been beneath him. But he also has this gorgeous sounding villa on the Laurentian coast, which is about 20 miles from Rome, where he talks about, in terms that would be, I think, instantly familiar to anyone looking to rent a very, very upmarket kind of holiday house, maybe on the Cote d'Azur or Big Sur or whatever. I mean, absolutely gorgeous. He talks, you know, he has a swimming pool. He has a dining room that's surrounded on three sides by the sea. He says that the base is washed by the foam of the waves.
那与他的身份不符。但他在劳伦提亚姆海岸也有一栋听起来美极了的别墅，距离罗马大约20英里。他谈论这栋别墅时的语气，我想，对于任何想要在蔚蓝海岸、大苏尔或类似地方租一栋非常非常高端的度假屋的人来说，会感到无比熟悉。我的意思是，绝对美极了。他讲到，你知道的，他有一个游泳池。他有一个三面环海的餐厅。他说地基都被海浪的泡沫冲刷着。
So absolutely gorgeous. Originally, we were going to, we've done three episodes, haven't we, on the kind of the rise of the modern holiday. And it just made me think, is it worth comparing the modern experience of holidays and tourism? You know, are there any parallels in antiquity? Because in lots of ways, I mean, in some ways, it seems a kind of foolish question. It's such a different world. But I think that Pliny's description of what is basically his holiday home, it does kind of raise kind of potentially interesting parallels, I think. I mean, the difference, of course, is that Pliny owns it outright. He's not renting it or anything like
所以绝对美极了。原本我们打算，我们已经做了三期节目，对吧，关于现代度假的兴起。这让我不禁思考，将现代的度假和旅游体验拿来做个比较，有意义吗？你知道，古代有任何相似之处吗？因为在很多方面——从某种程度上看——这似乎是个愚蠢的问题。这是一个如此不同的世界。但我认为普林尼对他基本上可以说是度假屋的描述，确实在某种程度上引发了一些潜在的有趣相似之处。我的意思是，当然，区别在于普林尼拥有它的完全产权。他不是在租房或者做类似的事情
that. No, but rich people have always had holiday homes that they owned outright, Tom. I mean, that doesn't make him different from lots of people who have holiday homes in Cornwall or in France or, you know, Americans who have houses on Cape Cod or something. I mean, I suppose that would be very familiar, wouldn't it? I mean, the idea of the holiday, I guess our idea of the holiday is a holy day, right? That's where the holiday is. That's the descent and that's the break. I mean, dare I say the coming of Christianity.ity well well you say that but i mean the romans did have holidays in the sense of holy days so um da's ferialis they called them so these were holidays defined by the state so they they were religious commemorated festivals of the gods
不，但有钱人一直都拥有他们全资拥有的度假屋，汤姆。我的意思是，这并没有使他与许多在康沃尔、法国拥有度假屋的人，或者你知道的，在科德角等地拥有房子的美国人有什么不同。我的意思是，我想这会非常熟悉，不是吗？我的意思是，度假的概念——我想我们对假期的概念是一个神圣的日子，对吧？这就是假期的由来。那是某种精神沉淀，也是一种休息。我的意思是，我敢说，基督教的到来。好吧，你这么说，但我的意思是，罗马人确实有假期，也就是圣日，所以他们称之为——他们称之为“法定期假”（dies ferialis）。所以这些是由国家规定的假期——它们是宗教纪念神祇的节日
or anniversaries or um they were they were holidays announced by senior magistrates or all that kind of stuff. And then you have as well, you have the games. So these are also, they're not officially holidays, but you get the day off if you're living in Rome. So that's the whole, that's the circuses aspect of the bread and circuses. It's one of the perks of living in Rome
或者是周年纪念，或者是……由高级长官宣布的假期，诸如此类的东西。然后你也有竞技比赛。所以这些也不是官方假期，但如果你住在罗马，你就能放假。所以这就是“面包与马戏”中马戏这一方面的全部内容。住在罗马的好处之一
is that you do get all these spectacles. But I suppose the question is, are there parallels with, as you say, people going off to their holiday home in Cornwall or Cape Cod or whatever? Because I think there probably are, because these are perks of the rich in the way that we would understand them today. And they're the kind of things that you don't get in the Middle Ages, I think. You don't get in the Elizabethan period. You don't tend to get people going off to villas by the sea in the way that we have them now. Yeah, it's interesting that in that opening description,
就是你可以看到所有这些奇观。但我想问题是，正如你所说，这与人们去康沃尔、科德角或其他地方的度假屋有没有相似之处？因为我认为可能确实有，因为这些可以说是我们今天所理解的富人的特权。而且这些都是你在中世纪时看不到的东西，我认为。你在伊丽莎白时期也看不到。你不会看到人们像我们现在这样成群结队地去海边别墅度假。是的，有趣的是，在开头的描述中
so, I mean, as you say, it's like an Airbnb, a very high class, an Airbnb plus, Tom. class um an airbnb plus um tom it's uh it's um it's a you know he says uh the sun the sea the woods the silence so he's i mean this is a great argument that historians always have with each other whether some things are constant whether some you know things that we desire luxuries or our sense of what is beautiful or whatever whether these things are constant or whether they're entirely socially and culturally conditioned but plinny seems to like in his in his sort of i mean this is this is his retreat right this is the his country house is that i mean he seems to like in that everything that we like in holiday home so in other words the sun the sea
所以，我的意思是，正如你所说，这就像是一个爱彼迎（Airbnb），一个非常高级的爱彼迎Plus，汤姆。高级的……爱彼迎Plus，汤姆。这……这是一个，你知道的，他说……阳光、大海、树林、宁静。所以他是在……这是历史学家们经常争论的一个伟大议题：某些事物是否是不变的，某些我们渴望的奢侈品、我们对美的理解或类似的东西，究竟是不变的，还是完全受到社会和文化条件的制约？但普林尼似乎很喜欢——在他那种……我的意思是，这是他的隐居地，对吧？这是他的乡间别墅。我的意思是，他似乎很喜欢所有我们在度假屋里喜欢的东西——换句话说，阳光、大海
the silence they are all constants the romans prize them just as much as we do and the dining with the sea all around i mean that's such a yeah you know it's you go to an aegean island and you get the you know the table looking out over the the sunset or whatever i mean that's exactly what plinny is talking about um and one of the things i think that is different although actually again i, thinking about what we were talking about over the past three episodes, this nervous sense that holidays, you know, that you should improve yourself. So the Romans do, you know, they absolutely have that. So they have this phrase, otium cum dignitate. It's kind of leisure where you're not disgracing yourself, basically.
宁静，这些都是不变的。罗马人对它们的珍视程度不亚于我们。还有那种被大海环绕的用餐体验——我的意思是，这太……你知道的，你去爱琴海的一个岛屿，就能享受到那种看着夕阳西下的餐桌，诸如此类。这正是普林尼所谈论的……而且我认为不同的一点在于——不过话说回来，回想一下我们过去三期节目所讨论的内容——这种焦虑感：度假，你知道的，你应该提升自己。所以罗马人确实，你知道的，他们绝对有这种想法。所以他们有一个短语：otium cum dignitate（有尊严的闲暇）。这是一种不会让自己丢脸的闲暇，基本上就是
Leisure where you are reading up on philosophy or doing elevated contemplation of the nature of the gods or that kind of thing. So there's this nervousness about being lazy, about being luxurious, about becoming soft. And yet, of course, at the same time, that is the index of how much they wanted it. And Pliny's Villa is west of Rome, but really the epicenter of this kind of craving for the sea, fine dining, novel experiences is a bit south of Rome. And it's an area of Italy that to this day remains an absolute kind of tourist honeypot. And that's the Bay of Naples. And the appeal of the Bay of Naples for Romans is that it's very rich. It's very beautiful.
一种你在阅读哲学书籍，或者对神灵的本质进行崇高沉思的闲暇。所以人们对于懒惰、对于奢侈、对于变得软弱有一种焦虑。然而，当然，与此同时，这也是他们对此渴望程度的指标。普林尼的别墅在罗马以西，但实际上，这种对大海、美食和新奇体验的渴望的震中在罗马南部一点。那是意大利的一个地区，直到今天依然是一个绝对的旅游蜜罐。那就是那不勒斯湾。那不勒斯湾对罗马人的吸引力在于它非常富庶。它非常美丽
It's kind of absolute, you know, the natural beauties are profound, but it's also has a flavor of Greece. So you can go to the Bay of Naples and you can genuinely feel that you are sampling something Hellenic because Naples and Neapolis, the new city, that was founded by Greek colonists. Other cities as well along that stretch of what the Romans called Campania is still called Campania to this day, provide visiting Romans with, you know, you can meet Greek philosophers, you can get Greek speaking prostitutes, all these kind of things that Greece as well holds out. But you don't have to travel all the way to Greece to get them. So they have the same thing that we have, Tom, which is the desire for escapism and exoticism, right? I mean, that's what we look for on holidays.
那种自然的壮丽是深邃的，但它也带有一点希腊的风味。所以你可以去那不勒斯湾，真切地感受到你在体验某种希腊风情，因为那不勒斯（Neapolis，意为“新城”）是由希腊殖民者建立的。沿着罗马人称之为坎帕尼亚（Campania，至今仍叫坎帕尼亚）的那片海岸的其他城市，也为来访的罗马人提供了……你知道的，你可以结识希腊哲学家，你可以找说希腊语的妓女，以及希腊所拥有的所有这类其他东西。但你不必大老远跑去希腊就能得到它们。所以他们和我们有一样的心态，汤姆，那就是对逃避现实和异国情调的渴望，对吧？我的意思是，这就是我们在度假时所寻求的。
Not too much exoticism. So I suppose it's a little bit like the Grand Tour, that on the Grand Tour, people are generally going to Rome and to Italy because that's familiar to them from their education. And likewise for Romans, they educated Romans, elite Romans are being brought up by Greek tutors. They're studying Greek literature. They're studying Greek philosophy. And so the chance to sample a little bit of Greece, albeit in Campania, is extremely appealing. They're not going off on adventure holidays to Gaul or anything like that. That's not what they want. A quick question. So the people that we're talking about are a very tiny minority, presumably. Yeah.
不要太异国情调。所以我想这有点像“壮游”（Grand Tour），在壮游中，人们通常去罗马和意大利，因为通过教育，这些地方对他们来说很熟悉。同样，对于罗马人来说，受过教育的罗马人、精英罗马人都是由希腊家庭教师抚养长大的。他们学习希腊文学。他们学习希腊哲学。因此，有机会体验一点希腊风情，尽管是在坎帕尼亚，也是极其诱人的。他们不会去高卢进行冒险之旅或类似的事情。那不是他们想要的。一个简单的问题。所以我们谈论的这些人，大概是极少数吧。是的。
That are pretty similar, probably, are they, to the grand tourists, to the social, to the idea of a rich, educated elite? I mean, most Romans never go on any form of holiday, presumably. Absolutely, yes. So these are a minority of a minority. These are absolutely, you know, maybe 500 people. And even then, maybe only, you know, 50 can afford the absolute kind of top quality properties. But these are the guys who are writing the letters. These are the people who are writing, you know, whose testimony survives. And and of course as is always the way with
他们可能和壮游者很相似，对吧，在社会属性上，在富有、受过教育的精英这个概念上？我的意思是，大多数罗马人大概从来不会去进行任何形式的度假吧？绝对是的。所以这些是少数中的少数。这些绝对是，你知道的，也许就500人。即便如此，可能也只有，你知道的，50人能买得起最顶级的房产。但这些人正是写信的人。这些人是那些正在写作、你知道的，其证词得以保存下来的人。当然，正如古代历史一贯的方式那样
ancient history we're dependent on the sources but what you do get at the beginning of the first century bc um you get a figure who in so far as it's possible to find a roman equivalent of thomas cook you know thomas cook the guy who is packaging everything together and selling it to people who want a flavor of, who want relaxation. It's a guy called Sergius Arata, who in the 90s BC develops the oyster beds of Campania, which are celebrated as the best oysterbeds in Italy. He develops them, he builds dikes, he builds channels, all this kind of stuff, turns the Lucrine Lake into this vast expanse of oyster farming. So that serves to attract gourmands, foodies, food snobs. But then on top of that, he seems to have invented the heating swimming pool. It's a Latin phrase that is much contested, but the likeliest explanation is that he's built kind
我们依赖于史料，但在公元前1世纪初，你会发现一个人物——在尽可能找到罗马版托马斯·库克（Thomas Cook）的范围内，你知道的，托马斯·库克就是那个把一切打包好并卖给想要体验、想要放松的人的家伙。这个人的名字叫塞尔吉乌斯·阿拉塔（Sergius Orata）。他在公元前90年代开发了坎帕尼亚的牡蛎养殖场，这些养殖场被誉为意大利最好的牡蛎养殖场。他开发了它们，修建了堤坝，建造了水渠，诸如此类，把卢克林湖（Lucrine Lake）变成了一个广阔的牡蛎养殖基地。这吸引了美食家、老饕、美食 snobs（美食势利小人）。但除此之外，他还似乎发明了加热游泳池。这是一个饱受争议的拉丁语短语，但最合理的解释是他建造了一种
of a swimming area that can be heated. So that's something attractive. And then on top of that, it seems that he is buying up lots of land, installing these heated swimming pools, developing the property sites and selling them to high-end clients in Rome. And so over the course of the first century BC, the line of the coast along the Bay of Naples, high-end properties with swimming pools seem to sprout up. So it's rather like California or Southern France. Yeah know southern france yeah the french riviera the french riviera and um we know of one of these kind of high-end houses is owned by the great general marius multiple consul great military uh leader um professionalizes the roman legions yeah and he has this property that is built we're told on a promontory on a rocky
可以加热的游泳区。所以这很有吸引力。除此之外，他似乎还买下了大量土地，安装了这些加热游泳池，开发了房产并将它们出售给罗马的高端客户。因此，在公元前1世纪期间，那不勒斯湾沿岸的海岸线上，带游泳池的高端房产如雨后春笋般涌现。所以这有点像加利福尼亚或法国南部。是的，你知道的，法国南部，是的，法国里维埃拉，法国里维埃拉，而且……我们知道其中一栋高端住宅是由伟大的将军马略（Marius）拥有的，他曾多次担任执政官、伟大的军事领袖，使罗马军团职业化，是的，他拥有这处房产，据说建在一个岬角上，一个岩石岬角上
promontory and that seems to be an absolutely key part of the appeal that you are kind of sticking out into the sea and one of the other things that you can get in the bay of naples is that you have this ash that that we know has been is volcanic they didn necessarily, but it has a remarkable property that it can set underwater. And so this facilitates the development of kind of piers that start jutting out into the sea. So again, a bit like Brighton, you're able to provide people with the opportunity to walk out and feel that you're surrounded by the sea. the romans are much too smart tom to be drinking seawater like in brighton right yeah they're probably not drinking seawater but they are going to spas are they i was going to ask about spas yeah they are so of course um the bay of
这似乎是其吸引力的一个绝对关键部分，那就是你某种程度上突入大海之中。在那不勒斯湾，你还能得到的另一件事是，你有这种火山灰——我们知道它是火山喷发形成的，他们当时不一定知道，但它具有一种非凡的特性，那就是它能在水下凝固。这便利了开始向海中延伸的码头的发展。所以，再次重申，有点像布赖顿，你能够为人们提供这样一种机会：走出去，感觉自己被大海环绕。罗马人太聪明了，汤姆，才不会像在布赖顿那样喝海水呢，对吧？是的，他们可能不喝海水，但他们要去温泉浴场，对吧？我正想问关于温泉浴场的事。是的，他们确实去。所以当然，那不勒斯湾
naples it's a very full of volcanic you know activity so there are lots and lots of sulfur baths all kinds of things like that and actually um the most notorious of all the pleasure resorts on the Bay of Naples, a place called Bailly, is celebrated for its sulphur baths. These sulphur baths, a bit like Brighton, provide an opportunity for the development of spectacular architecture because this concrete that can be used to set underwater also has the – its quality is such that Roman engineers can start to develop a spectacular new architectural form, namely the dome. And Baiae is famous for having the largest dome in the world. And it spreads over hot pools, sulfur baths, and it's rather like um the prince regent's spectacular in brighton this serves as the kind of you know the absolute landmark for by it's synonymous with all the kind
到处都是火山活动，所以有很多很多的硫磺浴，诸如此类的各种浴场。实际上，那不勒斯湾最声名狼藉的度假胜地——一个叫巴亚（Baiae）的地方，就以其硫磺浴而闻名。这些硫磺浴有点像布赖顿，为壮观建筑的发展提供了机会，因为这种可以在水下凝固的混凝土，其品质也使得罗马工程师能够开始开发一种壮观的新建筑形式，即穹顶。巴亚以拥有世界上最大的穹顶而闻名。它横跨在温泉池、硫磺浴池之上，这相当类似于摄政王在布赖顿的壮举，这成为了巴亚的某种地标——绝对的地标，它成了巴亚所能提供的所有快乐和愉悦的代名词。它是古代世界的黑浦塔（Blackpool Tower）。好吧，它当然不是黑浦，因为黑浦是为工人阶级准备的，因为它是专属的，对吧？
of the pleasures and delights that uh that by has to offer it's the ancient world's blackpool tower well it's it's not blackpool of course because blackpool is for is for the working classes because it's exclusive right there is of course, because Blackpool is for the working classes. Because it's exclusive. Right. There is no equivalent because the working people cannot afford to go there. But the rich can. And so it's probably, it's more like Brighton. So, Tom, when the rich go, do they all own properties?
当然，因为黑浦是为工人阶级准备的。因为它是专属的。对吧。没有与之对应的替代品，因为普通人去不起那里。但富人去得起。所以它可能，它更像布赖顿。所以，汤姆，当富人们去的时候，他们都拥有房产吗？
Are there rentals? Are there hotels? How does that work? They own their own properties right is there any i mean obviously there must have been um places where you stayed if you're a traveler a courier you know that kind of thing but is there any concept in rome of the the hotel as a place you stay for pleasure not really i don't think um but just down from by you have the great port of Potioli, which is vast. Again, it has kind of great harbour built out of this concrete that can set underwater.
有没有租赁的？有没有酒店？那是怎么运作的？他们拥有自己的房产，对吧？有没有什么——我的意思是，显然一定有供你住宿的地方，如果你是一个旅行者、信使，你知道，诸如此类——但在罗马，有没有“酒店”的概念，作为一个你为了享乐而住宿的地方？我觉得没有，不过……
And that's where all the grain ships come from that enable Rome to be sustained. But Potioli also is kind of, you know, there are lots and lots of hotels, there are lots of brothels. There are lots of places where people who aren't necessarily senators can kind of procure entertainment and enjoyment. So Satyricon, Petronius is kind of novel. People aren't quite sure what it is, but it's a kind of prose account of people who are not of the senatorial class. And it gives you an insight into what life would be like for them. And there are absolutely, it's almost certainly set in Potioli. And you almost certainly get a sense of the kind of opportunities that are there for people who aren't necessarily kind of senatorial, but there is fun to be had there. So all of this, it's not an exact mapping on to the contours of the modern tourist industry,
就在巴亚附近，有着庞大的波托奥利（Puteoli）港口。它非常巨大。同样，它也有用这种能在水下凝固的混凝土建造的巨大海港。那是所有运粮船到达的地方，这些运粮船维持着罗马的运转。但波托奥利也是某种……你知道的，那里有很多很多的酒店，有很多妓女。那里有很多地方，可以让那些不一定是元老院阶层的人获得娱乐和享受。所以佩特罗尼乌斯的《萨蒂利康》（Satyricon）这种小说……人们不太确定它到底是什么，但它是对非元老院阶层人们生活的一种散文记述。它让你得以一窥他们的生活是怎样的。而且毫无疑问，它几乎肯定以波托奥利为背景。你几乎肯定能感受到，对于那些不一定是元老院阶层的人来说，那里存在着怎样的机遇，而且在那里确实能找到乐趣。所以所有这些，它并不完全对应现代旅游业的轮廓，
but I do think that there are kind of echoes there oh they definitely are can i ask about a couple of things that um may or may not have existed so you mentioned the harbor would people i mean it would seem to me an obvious thing to do if i were a roman center that i might want to go on some form of cruise or some sort of you know take ship and go to greece go to egypt and look upon the pyramids or whatever. Do people ever do that? Do people ever go to the great temples in, I don't know, Ephesus or something or Athens? That's a great question. I think we should look at that in the second half. But on the question of, do they have yachts, say in the Bay of Naples? Absolutely they do. Yes,
但我确实认为其中存在着某种呼应。哦，它们绝对存在。我可以问几件……可能存在也可能不存在的事情吗？你提到了港口，人们会——对我来说，如果我是一个罗马元老，这似乎是一件显而易见的事：我可能会想去进行某种游轮旅行，或者某种……你知道，乘船去希腊、去埃及看看金字塔之类的。人们曾经这样做过吗？人们有没有去过埃菲索斯或雅典等地的大神庙？这是一个很好的问题。我想我们应该在下半场探讨这个问题。但关于“他们是否有游艇，比如说在那不勒斯湾？”这个问题，他们绝对有。是的，
absolutely they do. So at Bayeilly, again, which is the most notorious centre, part of the fun of it is that it's a place where you can let your hair down. And so you go out on a yacht and you get up to all the kinds of things perhaps that you wouldn't do even on dry land at Bailly. And so the know, strains of music and laughter are kind of drifting through the, you know, the warm nighttime air born from the yachts out in the bay is an absolutely key part of the appeal for people who can afford to go there. But it is, you know, if you if you spend too much time at Bailly, then people start to raise eyebrows. So Vespasian, for instance, a famously stern kind of old-fashioned type of emperor, ruggedly refuses to go to Bailly because he sees it as too decadent. But even he, in the very last year of his life, he succumbs to temptation and goes and has a lovely time but there is always this risk that that kind of hedges a wealthy roman constantly
他们绝对有。所以在巴亚——再次强调，这是那个最声名狼藉的中心——乐趣的一部分在于，这是一个你可以卸下防备、纵情欢乐的地方。所以你可以乘着游艇出海，去做各种你在巴亚的陆地上甚至都不会做的事情。因此，你知道的，从海湾里的游艇上飘进温暖夜空中的音乐和欢笑声，对于那些负担得起去那里的人来说，是吸引力的一个绝对核心部分。但它是……你知道的，如果你在巴亚呆的时间太长，人们就会开始挑起眉毛。比如韦斯帕西安（Vespasian），一个以严厉、老派著称的皇帝，就断然拒绝去巴亚，因为他认为那里太颓废了。但即便如此，在他生命的最后一年，他还是屈服于诱惑，去了并度过了一段美好的时光。然而，始终存在着这样一种风险，它时刻环绕着一个富有的罗马人：如果你做得过头了，人们就会开始认为你没干好事。
about that if you go too far then people start to assume that you're up to no good and the classic classic example of this is the emperor tiberius i was just going to ask about something so i've been to capri to the island that that Tiberius went to. And, of course, I think it's called the Villa Jovis. Yeah. So the Villa of Jupiter. The Villa of Jupiter, his luxury holiday home, which was a fantastic setting, overlooks the sea, and where famously, now maybe you'll be able to tell us
而这方面最经典、最极端的例子就是提比略皇帝。我正想问一件事——我曾经去过卡普里岛，也就是提比略去过的那座岛。而且，当然，我想它被称为“朱庇特别墅”（Villa Jovis）。是的。所以就是朱庇特别墅。朱庇特别墅，他的豪华度假屋，环境优美，俯瞰大海。据说正是在那里——也许现在你能告诉我们这是真是假——提比略隐居起来，并且在大规模地胡作非为。汤姆，你想给我们讲讲提比略的度假消遣吗？提比略是一个令人难以置信的、了不起的人。他是罗马最伟大的将军。在他的军事生涯中，他曾两次将罗马从大规模入侵中拯救出来，一次在多瑙河，一次在莱茵河。他受过极高、极高的教育，极高、极高的智商，极具文化素养，是一位杰出的行政长官，继承了奥古斯都的衣钵，作为皇帝统治国家。但我认为到他生命的尽头，他开始觉得自己已经做得够多了。他精疲力竭，对罗马厌烦了。他厌烦了他那双重角色中暗含的紧张关系，因为提比略是一个对共和国传统有着深厚忠诚的人。然而他基本上被迫承担了
whether this is true or not, Tiberius is supposed to have secluded himself and got up to no good on a very grand scale. Tom, do you want to tell us a bit about Tiberius's holiday pursuits? So Tiberius is an unbelievably impressive man. He is Rome's greatest general. Over the course of his military career, he twice saves Rome from a mass invasion, once on the Danube, once on the Rhine. He is highly, highly educated, highly, highly intelligent, very, very literate, a brilliant administrator, succeeds Augustus, rules as emperor. But I think by the end of his life, he's coming to feel that he has done enough. He is exhausted and he's fed up with Rome. He's fed up with the tensions implicit in his role because Tiberius is a man with a deep loyalty to the traditions of the Republic. And yet he has basically been obliged to take on the role of
奥古斯都的角色。所以是一个独裁的角色。我认为这个角色中的紧张关系对他来说变得太沉重了。因此他从罗马退隐，因为他觉得他配得上他的 otium cum dignitate，他的闲暇时间。他赢得了这个权利。于是他沿着海岸南下。他在一座别墅停了下来，那里有一个位于洞穴旁边的壮观餐厅，据说奥德修斯在航行时曾从这里驶过。
Augustus. So a kind of autocratic role. And I think that the tension in the role becomes too much for him. And so he retires from Rome because he feels that he deserves his otium cum dignitate, his leisure time. He's earned the right to it. And he heads down the coast. He stops off in one villa where he has a spectacular dining place beside a cave, which is illustrated where past which Odysseus is meant to have sailed on his voyages.
在这个用餐空间周围，有许多描绘奥德修斯航海经历的壮观雕塑。它有点破损了，因为发生了一场地震。提比略差点在地震中被压死，但他活了下来。然后他继续前行，最终找到了基本上是终极的退休胜地，也就是卡普里岛，它位于海湾外。所以它是完全隐蔽的。这就是他基本上定居下来且再也没有返回罗马的地方。朱庇特别墅据说是他建造的12座别墅之一，每一座都以奥林匹斯山的一位神明为原型。关于他在那里胡作非为，流传着令人震惊、真正令人震惊的故事。
And there's kind of spectacular statues illustrating the voyages of Odysseus all around this dining space. It's slightly ruined because there's an earthquake. And Tiberius almost gets crushed in the earthquake, but he survives that. And he then goes on and he ends up with basically the ultimate retirement place, which is the island of Capri, which is out in the bay. So it's completely secluded. And this is where he essentially settles and he doesn't come back to Rome. And the Villa Jovis is one supposedly of 12 villas that he builds, each one modeled on one of the gods of Olympus. And shocking, truly shocking stories are told of what he gets up to there. go swimming in his pool and have these small boys who swim alongside him and nibble at his genitals as they do so. Even more shocking things he's meant to do that I don't think that they can be... Suetonius, who describes this, one of the sentences with which he describes what Tiberius
去他的泳池游泳，身边还有一些小男孩陪着他游，并在游的时候啃咬他的生殖器。据说他还做过更让人震惊的事情，我觉得这些事情都不能……苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）描述了这一点，他在描述提比略在卡普里岛上胡作非为时所用的其中一个句子，我认为是整个古代文学中最令人震惊的一句话。甚至比我们上周听到的关于狄奥多拉的描述还要震撼。所以如果你想去了解那是什么，去读一本译本吧。我不会在这个播客里说出來。所以，问题显然是——正如我们讨论普罗科匹乌斯对查士丁尼和狄奥多拉的恶毒攻击时那样——这些传闻是从哪里来的？它准确吗？
is getting up to on Capri, I think is the single most shocking sentence in the whole of ancient literature. Even more shocking than the descriptions of Theodora that we had in last week. So if you want to go and find out what it is, go and read a translation. I won't say on this podcast. So the question, obviously, you know, as we discussed with Procopius bitching about Justinian and Theodora is what, you know, where is this coming from? Is it accurate?
关于提比略在卡普里岛上的所作所为，还有其他的记载，让这一切听起来无害得多。提比略据说很喜欢在温室里种蔬菜——这大不相同。他是一个……他是一个热衷于文学闲聊的人。他会举行简朴的晚餐，人们围坐在一起，他会招待文人，并为他们举办测验。是的。你知道的，相当于酒吧问答。这就像成为这个播客的会员一样，汤姆。你看。我们举办问答。非常相似。
There are other accounts of what Tiberius is getting up to on um a capri that make it sound a lot more innocent um tiberius is meant to have enjoyed growing vegetables in greenhouses that's very different he he was a he was he was a great man for literary chit-chat. He would have rather abstemious suppers where people would sit around and he would host literary people and he'd stage quizzes for them. Yeah. You know, equivalent of pub quizzes. It's like being a member of this podcast, Tom. There you go. We stage quizzes. Very similar.
非常相似，非常相似。所以这里面存在着某种紧张关系。我认为这反映了这样一个事实：基本上罗马人有一种默认的假设，即如果你花太多时间在别墅里隐居、孤立地寻欢作乐，那只能意味着绝对的堕落。说明你没干好事。绝对的堕落。换句话说，罗马人在潜意识里认为任何人都没有隐私权。你必须在公众注视下生活，如果你不这样做，那一定是因为你是个彻头彻尾的变态。你在从事各种令人作呕的活动。而提比略成了罗马生活中这种假设的“海报男孩”（典型代表）。
Very similar, very similar. And so there is a kind of tension there. And I think it reflects the fact that basically there is this default Roman assumption that if you spend too long having a good time, secluded, isolated in a villa, it can only mean utter depravity. That you are up to no good. Utter depravity. In other words, the Romans have no sense that anyone has a right to privacy. You lead your life in public because if you don't, it's because you're an absolute pervert. You're up to all kinds of revolting activities. And Tiberius becomes the kind of the showboy, I guess, the poster boy for that assumption in
显然，这其中有大量的阶级嫉妒，一直渗透到整个社会阶层的底层。但对提比略来说——我的意思是，对于那些理应是提比略同僚、却无法去卡普里岛的元老们来说，这是一种羞辱。卡普里岛为提比略一人专属。因此，如果他们想与皇帝有任何接触，就不得不去那不勒斯湾沿岸租房。这可能……贵得惊人。如果他们负担不起，那就太丢脸了。而且，你知道的，那些根本去不起那不勒斯湾的罗马人，当然会对此抱怨连天。是的，当然。我能插一句吗？这里面还有另一个维度吗？
Roman life. And obviously, there is an enormous amount of class envy in this, going right the way down the social scale. But for Tiberius, I mean, it's humiliating for senators who supposedly are Tiberius's peers that they can't get to Capri. Tiberius owns it exclusively. And so they are obliged, if they want to have any contact with the emperor, to kind of renting out properties along the Bay of naples which could be you know incredibly expensive and if they can't afford that then that's very humiliating um and it's you know and and people who can't afford to go to the bay of naples full stop in rome of course they're going to moan and complain about it yeah of course can i just jump in is there another dimension to this
我知道这是一个非常有趣的故事，关于提比略的故事——也就是他离开罗马，把罗马交给他信任的亲信塞扬努斯（Sejanus）去管理，而许多人讨厌塞扬努斯，认为他是暴君。所以他们是不是把对塞扬努斯的怨恨，很大程度上投射到了身处卡普里岛的提比略身上？是的，所以塞扬努斯实际上是在那场差点杀死提比略的地震中救了提比略的人。然后他继续……基本上他成了提比略的谋士，为他管理政务。而提比略最终意识到这可能并不明智，塞扬努斯正在密谋发动政变。于是他非常残酷地处决了塞扬努斯及其全家。是的，我的意思是，我认为这些都是真的。当然，这无助于改善人们对提比略的看法。但我认为人们觉得在危机时刻领导人不应该去度假的这种感觉，绝对是我们所能理解的。
um i i know that it's such an interesting story the the story of Tiberius, which is that he's left Rome to be run by his right-hand man, Sejanus, who a lot of people hate and think is tyrannical. And so they're projecting, are they projecting a lot of their resentment of Sejanus onto Tiberius on the island of Capri. Yeah, so Sejanus is the guy who actually saves Tiberius from the earthquake that almost kills him. And he then goes on to basically, he's kind of Tiberius' conciliary, I suppose, running for him. And Tiberius ends up realizing that perhaps this is unwise and that Sejanus is plotting a coup. And so has Sejanus dispatched very brutally and all his family. Yes, I mean, I think that that is all true. And of course, you know, that doesn't help with what people are saying about Tiberius. But I think that the sense that people feel that leaders should not be going on holiday when there are crises is absolutely something that we would recognise.
哦，是的。如果在危机期间你不在岗，就像多米尼克·拉布（Dominic Raab）或鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）之流。鲍里斯·约翰逊刚刚去度假了，不是吗？他去度蜜月了，人们对此颇有微词。而且我也认为有一种持续的感觉，即领导人不配享有他们最终可能得到的那些假期。所以人们对托尼·布莱尔（Tony Blair）做克利夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）或贝卢斯科尼等人的座上宾一直怨声载道。好吧，托尼·布莱尔去了一些非常、非常不明智的假期，我认为是的。所以我觉得人们觉得富人和权贵们正在经历普通民众在罗马和今天都无法享有的假期、乐趣和快乐，这引发了敌意。我认为
Oh, yeah. If you're away in a crisis, Dominic Raab or Boris Johnson or whatever. Boris Johnson's just been off on holiday, hasn't he? He's been on his honeymoon and people are complaining about that. And also, I think there's kind of constant feeling that leaders don't deserve to get the kind of holidays that they may end up getting. So there was constant complaints about Tony Blair having, you know, being the guest of Cliff Richard or Berlusconi or whoever. Well, Tony Blair went on some very, very ill-judged holidays, I think. Yeah. So I think that sense that people have that the rich and the powerful are experiencing holidays and enjoyments and pleasures that the mass of the people can't have in Rome as in today generated hostility. And I think that that
这也是尼禄（Nero）令人感兴趣的原因之一，他非常符合节目的调性。所以在我们关于尼禄的那期节目中，我们谈到了金宫（Domus Aurea），这是他在大火之后在罗马市中心建造的一个由宫殿、娱乐花园和湖泊组成的庞大综合体。对于元老们来说，这是一个怪物，因为基本上尼禄在做的事情，是把普林尼在开场所读的那段话中描述的、提比略在卡普里岛享受的那种豪华别墅，搬到了首都的心脏地带。因此，它一直被人们当作一个绝对的怪胎来记忆。但我认为，有理由说尼禄在做的事情是把自己包装成人民之友，因为他在给罗马人民一个体验……
is one of the things that Nero is interesting for, very much friend of the show. So in our episode on Nero, we talked about the golden house, which he built is this enormous kind of complex of palaces and pleasure gardens and lakes that he builds in the center of Rome after the Great Fire. And for senators, this is a monstrosity because basically what Nero is doing, he is bringing a luxury villa of the kind that Pliny described in the passage that you read at the opening that Tiberius enjoys on Capri into the heart of the capital. And so it's always remembered as an absolute monstrosity. But there is a case, I think, for saying that what Nero is doing is he's marketing himself as a friend of the people because he is giving people in Rome a chance to experience what
他们原本体验不到的东西的机会。所以你可以说尼禄扮演了一个非常、非常高端的比利·巴特林（Billy Butlin，英国度假营创始人）的角色。我正要说呢，难道关于尼禄和他的金宫，不是还有这样一种说法吗：实际上尼禄试图建造的是——我知道这是一个愚蠢的比较——某种罗马版本的像哥本哈根的蒂沃利（Tivoli）那样的娱乐花园，对吧？而蒂沃利当然也是迪士尼乐园以及后来的迪士尼世界的灵感来源。所以他在创造一个普通百姓能够和精英们一样享受的娱乐公园。是的，我认为这绝对是真的。而且
they would not otherwise have. So you could say that nero is playing the role of a very very upmarket billy butlin well i was about to say isn't there a claim about nero and his golden house that actually what nero is trying to build is a a roman antecedent of i mean i know it's a stupid comparison of something like tivoli in copenhagen pleasure gardens yeah which of course tivolioli, of course, was the inspiration for Disneyland and then Disney World. So he's creating a pleasure park that actually the common people will be able to enjoy as much as the elite. Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. And of
当然，这就是为什么元老院恨透了它并将其彻底抹去。但当然，将它抹去的皇帝是韦斯帕西安，那个极其严厉、坚毅的士兵，因为他太持重清教徒作风而拒绝去巴亚。但他知道，如果要抹去这个供人民尽情享乐的巨大湖泊、花园和树林聚集地，他必须用别的东西取而代之。于是他在这个遗址上建造了罗马最著名的纪念碑，即大竞技场（Colosseum）。大竞技场的落成典礼以及在大竞技场内举行的源源不断的庆祝活动、节日和公开竞技，让罗马的大众得以享受许多假期。我正想说，大竞技场，当然
course, that's why the Senate hates it and obliterate it. But of course, the emperor who obliterates it is Vespasian, the stern, rugged soldier who refuses to go to Dubai because he's so puritanical about it. But he knows that if he's going to obliterate this great kind of concentration of lakes and gardens and groves that the people have been enjoying, he has to replace it with something else. And so he builds Rome's most famous monument on the site, namely the Colosseum. And the inauguration of the Colosseum and the kind of constant celebrations and feast day and public games that are held in the Colosseum enable the masses in Rome to have a lot of holidays. I was about to say the Colosseum, of course,
人们在度假时会看到的一个地方，而韦斯帕西安大概不会赞成去参观大竞技场并吃个冰淇淋。我想他会很高兴知道它依然屹立不倒，并且人们仍然因它而记住他。我正想说我们一会儿该休息一下了，但你还有更多关于……没有，我想你没有。好吧，这真是难以置信，我觉得这太荒谬了。好吧，我想我们应该在下半场转入……你知道的，去国外旅游、诸如此类的行程。就这么办吧。我们在中场休息时收拾行李，在广告之后回来，准备好去度个“罗马假日”，就像那样。我是格里高利·派克。汤姆是奥黛丽·赫本。我们几分钟后见。拜拜。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德
a place that people see on holidays, which Vespasian presumably will not approve of, visiting the Colosseum and eating an ice cream. I think he'd be very happy to know that it was still standing and that he he was still remembered for it i was about to say we should take a break in a second but have you got more to say about um no i think you haven't well i'm unbelievable i find that utterly implausible well i thought we should move on in the second half to um you know to tourism going abroad trips like that let's do that we will pack move on in the second half to, you know, to tourism, going abroad. We will. Trips like that.
我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八盒八卦以及问答环节的地方
Let's do that. We will pack our bags in the commercial break and we will return after the adverts, poised to go on a Roman holiday, as it were. I'm Gregory Peck. Tom is Audrey Hepburn. And we'll see you in a couple of minutes. Bye bye. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde
我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场演出门票
and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们的行李已经打包好，护照也已准备就绪。汤姆，我们即将开启一次豪华游轮之旅、一次远航，随你怎么称呼它。那么我们正前往哪里？
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
我们要去希腊，因为当然，你知道的，对罗马人来说，希腊世界真的就像四五十年代和六十年代美国游客眼中的欧洲一样。这是一个你可以觉得自己很富有，同时又能享受一些古老世界文化的地方。所以我觉得这个类比相当贴切。精英罗马人学习荷马史诗，学习希腊哲学。希腊的著名遗址——雅典、斯巴达、德尔斐、奥林匹亚——对罗马人来说具有共鸣，就像伦敦、巴黎或罗马对美国人那样。是的。这些地方你从小就耳熟能详。所以你很可能会想去看看。我们有记录以来第一个这样做的人——基本上是进行了一次某种意义上的观光游览、参观遗址——是罗马历史上一个非常杰出的军事人物，卢修斯·埃米利乌斯·保卢斯（Lucius Aemilius Paulus）。他是那个在坎尼战役中阵亡的执政官的儿子，在那场战役中，汉尼拔取得了对罗马的大屠杀式胜利，这是罗马共和国历史上遭受的最惨重的失败。他也是小西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）的父亲，小西庇阿后来将彻底摧毁迦太基。我们的保卢斯对罗马军事荣耀的贡献在于，他在公元前168年的彼得纳战役（Battle of Pydna）中击败了马其顿国王珀尔修斯（Perseus）。
head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Our bags are packed, passports prepared. Tom, we're about to embark on a pleasure cruise, a voyage, call it what you will. So where are we heading?
因此元老院授予了他“马其顿征服者”（Macedonicus）的称号。非常棒。所以那是他的……是的，这是一个辉煌的头衔。在他赢得彼得纳战役的第二年，他回到了希腊本土和伊庇鲁斯（Epirus）王国。伊庇鲁斯基本上就是现在的阿尔巴尼亚，对吧？奥林匹亚斯就是从那里来的，她曾在历史版的《爱情岛》上呆过，是亚历山大大帝的母亲。
We're heading for Greece because of course, you know, the Greek world really, I suppose for Romans is what Europe was for American tourists in the, maybe the forties and the fifties and the sixties. It was, you know, it was a place where you could feel rich, but you could enjoy some good old world culture. So I think the parallel is quite a neat one. And elite Romans are studying Homer, they're studying Greek philosophy. The famous sites in Greece, Athens, Sparta, Delphi, Olympia, are places with resonance for Romans in the way that, say, London or Paris or Rome would be for Americans. Yeah. These are places that you are familiar with from your childhood. And so you may well want to see them. And the first person that we have kind of record of doing this, basically going on a kind of an equivalent of a tour, looking at the sites, is a very distinguished military figure in Roman history, Lucius Aemilius Paulus, who is the son of the consul that dies at the Battle of Cannae, where Hannibal, you know, this great murderous victory over Rome, the worst defeat that the
保卢斯开始了他的行动。四处走动。他狠狠地教训了伊庇鲁斯人一番。他洗劫了他们的一些城市。他进行掠夺并做了所有类似的事情。然后他决定去希腊各地巡游一番。李维（Livy）在他的《罗马史》中对此有精彩的描述。
Roman Republic ever suffered. And he's the father of Scipio Aemilianus, who will go on to destroy Carthage. Our Paulus's contribution to Roman military glory is that he defeats the King of Macedon, Perseus, at the Battle of Pydna in 168. and so he gets given by the senate the the subraca macedonicus um very good so that's his kind of yeah so it's splendid a splendid title and the year after he has um he's won the battle of pidna he goes back to the greek mainland and the kingdom of apyrus which is kind of of Albania, basically, isn't it? It's where Olympias, who was on the historical Love Island, the mother of Alexander the Great, came from.
他说当时大约是秋季。所以这挺有意思的。如果你是罗马人，你不会想在夏天旅行，因为太热了，所以你要在秋天去。保卢斯决定利用这个季节刚开始的时机周游希腊，去参观那些因为传闻而变得如此著名的地方——以至于人们听说它们时，觉得它们比实际亲眼看到时要更加宏伟。
And Paulus does his stuff. He goes around. He kind of beats the crap out of the Epirots. He sacks some of their cities. He loots and does all that kind of stuff. And then he decides he would like to go on a tour round Greece. And Livy, in his History of Rome, has a brilliant description of it.
然后保卢斯开始行动。他四处巡视，把伊庇鲁斯人狠狠地揍了一顿。他洗劫了他们的一些城市，大肆掠夺。接着，他决定去希腊各地游览一番。李维在他的《罗马史》中对此有精彩绝伦的描写。
And he says that it was now about the season of autumn. So that's kind of interesting. You don't want to go travelling in the summer because it's too hot if you're Roman, so you go in the autumn. Paulus decided to take advantage of the beginning of this season by travelling round Greece to visit the places which have become so famous by report that they are taken on hearsay as more impressive than they proved to be when actually seen.
他说当时大约是秋季。这挺有意思的。罗马人认为夏天太热不适合旅行，所以要在秋天出行。保卢斯决定利用这个季节的开始周游希腊，去参观那些名声在外、仅凭传闻就让人觉得比实际亲眼所见还要宏伟的地点。
Oh, no. The perennial holiday problem. Yeah, I think that must be the first account in, I mean, maybe if there's an earlier one, I'd love to hear it, if listeners can think of one. But as far as I know, that's the first account of sites that turn out to be not quite as impressive as you think they're going to be. So Paulus goes off and he goes to Delphi and he goes to Athens. He goes to Corinth, goes to Argos, he goes to Sparta, he goes to Olympia. And then he goes to olympia um and then he goes back and we talked didn't we uh over all three of the previous episodes about how modern tourists want to bring stuff back to show that they've been to a place so um you know you or i might bring back a a knickknack um yeah lords
哦，不。这是历久弥新的假期老问题。对，我想这绝对是第一笔相关记载，我是说，如果还有更早的，听众朋友们要是能想到，我很乐意听听。但据我所知，那是关于那些实际上并没有想象中那么震撼的景点的最早记载。所以保卢斯出发了，他去了德尔斐，去了雅典。他去了科林斯，去了阿尔戈斯，去了斯巴达，去了奥林匹亚。然后他去了奥林匹亚，嗯，接着他回去了，我们在之前的三集节目里不是讨论过吗，关于现代游客想要带些东西回去，以证明他们去过某个地方，所以，你知道，你或者我可能会带回一件小玩意儿……对，贵族老爷们
millords going to rome might bring back a classical statue. Lord Elgin would bring some marbles. Yeah. Paulus brings back, you know, ships crammed full of loot. Absolutely huge, huge amounts of loot.
去罗马的贵族老爷可能会带回一件古典雕像。埃尔金勋爵会带走一些大理石雕刻。对。保卢斯带回来的，你知道，则是装满战利品的船只。绝对是海量、海量的战利品。
And this is what Roman generals from this point on, whenever they hit the Greek world and they have a chance to get embroiled in a war, they seize it with open arms. And so the most notorious figure who does this is a guy called Lucius Mummius, who in 146 is served up on a platter the opportunity to sack the famous city of Corinth. And Corinth is famous for its bronzes. It's famous for its statuary. And it's famous again, as Naples was, for its prostitutes. So Mummius wipes Corinth from the face of the earth. And the keys are loaded with bronzes, statues, works of art, prostitutes, all of which are loaded onto the ships, taken back to Rome. And Mamis can say, you know, he had a splendid time in Greece.
从这一点开始，基本上只要罗马将军们踏足希腊世界，有机会卷入战争，他们就会双臂张开、欣然抓住这个机会。最臭名昭著的人物是一个叫卢修斯·穆米乌斯的人，他在公元前146年得到了一个现成的机会，去洗劫著名的科林斯城。科林斯以青铜器闻名。它以雕塑闻名。而且它和那不勒斯一样，以妓女闻名。于是穆米乌斯将科林斯从大地上抹去了。港口停满了青铜器、雕像、艺术品、妓女，所有这些都被装上船，带回了罗马。穆米乌斯可以说是度过了一段光辉灿烂的希腊之旅。
And from that point on, basically, you know, all these villas that we were talking about in the first part of this episode are stuffed full, you know, this is where you get your antiquities. This is where you get your... But there's no, I mean, the difference in then and now is there's no there's clearly no resentment of this presumably i mean there isn't a sort of movement later or 200 years later people say oh you should restitute no yeah restitute no no no of course not and interestingly of course i mean you know on the topic of the elkin marbles um the the parthenon was built with loot that the athenians
从那时起，基本上，你知道，我们在这集前半部分谈到的所有这些别墅里都塞满了东西，你知道，这就是你获取古代文物的地方。这就是你获取……但这没有，我是说，当时和现在的区别在于，当时显然没有人对此感到不满，大概吧，我是说，后来或200年后并没有出现那种人们说“哦，你们应该归还文物”的运动，不，不，不，当然没有。有趣的是，当然，你知道，说到埃尔金勋爵的大理石雕刻……帕台农神庙是用雅典人从他们的臣民身上勒索来的战利品建造的……
extorted from their subjects um and when in due course uh marius's great rival sulla gets the chance to sack athens you know he kind of basically says well you know this is payback so he he um he he he storms athens and he he nicks all kinds of stuff so he nicks the complete works of aristotle you know it'd be like i suppose i don't know people stealing the contents of the british library or something like that the vatican library you know taking them back to washington or something like that exactly um well it's pretty much what the nazis did isn't it i mean this was yeah of course this is anyone kind of pillaging you know in warsaw or cracow or whatever they would yeah they would load up with your tapestries and books and all this kind of stuff absolutely and there's this large uh temple to zeus that's been
当后来马略的死敌苏拉有机会洗劫雅典时，你知道，他基本上会说，好吧，你知道，这是因果报应，所以他，嗯，他，他，他突袭了雅典，顺走了各种各样的东西。所以他顺走了亚里士多德的全集，你知道，这大概就像，我不知道，有人偷走了大英图书馆的藏品之类的，或者梵蒂冈图书馆的藏品，你知道，把它们带回华盛顿或诸如此类的地方。完全是这样。嗯，这几乎就是纳粹做的事，不是吗？我的意思是，这当然是任何人，你知道的，在华沙或克拉科夫等地劫掠时，他们都会装满挂毯、书籍和这类东西。绝对是这样。而且还有这座大型的宙斯神庙，它当时在雅典还
unfinished in athens with all these kind of pillars standing there and um sullen knows that that the temple of jupiter back on the capital in Rome has burnt down. So he just takes them back to Rome. So it's all very Lord Elgin behavior. And you asked about how do the Greeks feel about this? There's actually, there's a really, this is quite a bit later. So this is the early second century. But there's a kind of philosopher stroke scholar called dio who comes um from the city called prusa in uh bithynia which is now kind of northern northern turkey
没有完工，到处都是竖立着的柱子，嗯，苏拉知道罗马卡皮托利山上朱庇特神庙被烧毁了。所以他直接把这些柱子搬回了罗马。这完全是埃尔金勋爵式的行为。你问希腊人对此作何感想？实际上，这有点……这已经是相当长一段时间之后了。这是公元二世纪初。但有一个类似于哲学家兼学者的叫狄奥的人，他来自比提尼亚一个叫普鲁萨的城市，现在大概是土耳其北部
um just down from the bosphorus sea of marmora um and he visits roads and he's appalled by what he finds the rodians are doing to flatter visiting Roman dignitaries, so Roman tourists. Yeah. What the Rhodians are doing is they are taking statues of, you know, famous Rhodian heroes, often dating hundreds of years back. And they're erasing the names of the people to whom these statues originally portrayed and chiseling in the names of Romans. Oh, that is poor. That is very poor form. Yeah. And Dio is appalled by this and says, you know, you're, you're, you're wiping out your history. You're erasing your history. Yeah. But he also notes that the Romans have, have carted off a lot of statues from Rhodes
就在博斯普鲁斯海峡和马尔马拉海的南边，他访问了罗得岛，他对罗得岛人为了奉承来访的罗马显贵（也就是罗马游客）而做的事情感到震惊。是的。罗得岛人做的事情是，他们把那些（你知道的）罗得岛著名英雄的雕像搬出来，这些雕像通常可以追溯到几百年前。他们抹去了这些雕像原本描绘的人的名字，然后凿上了罗马人的名字。哦，这太差劲了。这行径实在太恶劣了。是的。狄奥对此感到震惊，并表示，你知道，你们在抹杀你们的历史。你们在抹除你们的历史。是的。但他也注意到，罗马人从罗得岛运走了大量的雕像，
and he doesn't, he doesn't mind this. And in fact, he, he rather approves of it. And he says says it's true that the romans have carried off statues from everywhere including roads but this was to adorn their city where the objects are much better off than in some obscure corner of greece so actually dio is saying you know this is this is kind of saying well it's much better for the for the uh parthenophoresis to be in london where everyone can come and see them. It's almost identical argument. So kind of interesting. And do the Romans, Tom, do they go further east?
而且他并不介意这一点。事实上，他相当赞成。他说，诚然，罗马人从各地（包括罗得岛）搬走了雕像，但这这是为了装饰他们的城市，在那些地方，这些物品比在希腊某个默默无闻的角落里要好得多。所以实际上狄奥是在说，你知道，这有点像在说，嗯，帕台农神庙的饰带最好还是放在伦敦，在那里每个人都可以来看。这几乎是完全相同的论点。这挺有趣的。那么罗马人，汤姆，他们会去更东边吗？
Do they go, would they go to, for example, to Asia Minor? Would they go to what's now Turkey? Would they go to Egypt? They would. So Ephesus is a great center. I mean, all the cities that have some, say Troy, places that have some kind of mythological, historical resonance. That's what they're interested in. Or indeed, kind of reputation for great art, great statuary.
他们会去，比如说，小亚细亚吗？他们会去现在的土耳其吗？他们会去埃及吗？他们会的。所以以弗索是一个巨大的中心。我是说，所有那些拥有某种，比如特洛伊，那些具有某种神话、历史共鸣的地方。这就是他们感兴趣的。或者确实，那些以伟大的艺术、伟大的雕塑而闻名的地方。
And it's this kind of combination of, I suppose, of art and the numinous, the mythological, that is really what Roman tourists want. But that's a bit like the grand, that's the grand tourists, isn't it? I mean, they're looking for uplift and aesthetics and, but also fun. And I suppose Romans would have been the same. Completely.
这就是艺术与超自然力量、神话色彩的某种结合，这才是罗马游客真正想要的。但这有点像壮游，不是吗？我是说，他们在寻找精神上的升华、美学，还有乐趣。我想罗马人也是一样的。完全如此。
So on the, I mean, on the subject of the great tour, we talked about Byron in our first episode. And, you know, he goes on, he actually goes to Greece. And in Childe Harold, he's writing about Cicero, the great Roman orator. And he quotes a letter that was written to Cicero by a guy called Servius Salpichus, just after Cicero's daughter has died. And Salpichus writes to Cicero, basically trying to cheer him up, saying, you know,
所以，关于壮游这个话题，我们在第一集里谈到了拜伦。而且，你知道，他继续旅行，他 실제로（实际上）去了希腊。在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中，他写到了西塞罗，这位伟大的罗马演说家。他引用了一封由一个叫塞尔维乌斯·苏尔皮库斯的人写给西塞罗的信，就在西塞罗的女儿去世后不久。苏尔皮库斯写信给西塞罗，基本上是想安慰他，说，你知道，
worst things happen at sea. It's basically chin up, that kind of thing. And Byron appends this note. He says, the celebrated letter of of servius subpictures to cicero on the death of his daughter describes as it then was and now is a path which i often traced in greece both by sea and land in different journeys and voyages and then he quotes subpictures on my return from asia as i was sailing from aegina towards megara i began to contemplate the prospect of the countries around me. Aegina was behind, Megara before me, Piraeus on the right, Corinth on the left, all which towns, once famous and flourishing, now lie overturned and buried in their ruins. And upon this sight, I could not but think presently with myself, alas, how do we poor
海里还会发生更糟糕的事呢。基本上就是振作点，诸如此类的话。拜伦附上了这段注释。他说，塞尔维乌斯·苏尔皮库斯写给西塞罗的关于其女之死的著名信件，描述了（当时和现在都是如此）我在希腊通过水路和陆路在不同的旅行和航行中经常追踪的一条路线，然后他引用了苏尔皮库斯的话：当我从亚洲归来时，正当我从埃伊纳岛航行向迈加拉时，我开始沉思周围国家的景象。埃伊纳岛在身后，迈加拉在前方，比雷埃夫斯在右侧，科林斯在左侧，所有这些曾经著名且繁荣的城镇，如今都倾覆并埋葬在废墟之中。看到这一幕，我不禁立刻对自己说，唉，我们这些可怜的
mortals fret and vex ourselves if any of our friends happen to die or be killed whose life is yet so short when the carcasses of so many noble cities lie here exposed before me in one view so aegan omega piraeus corinth these are all cities that kind of lie around athens and what you're getting there is that kind of shiver that tourists still get today or dream of getting because they don't anymore because so many tourists tend to go to antique you know ancient sites but the dream is of stumbling across some ancient city in its vastness and loneliness and feeling that kind of shiver down your spine and clearly what what salpichis is articulating is pretty much the same sentiment um you get a kind of shiver from thinking that which was great is no
凡人，如果我们的任何朋友碰巧死去或遇害，生活本来就如此短暂，我们却还要为此感到苦恼和烦心，而无数伟大城市的遗骸此刻却一览无余地陈列在我眼前。所以埃伊纳、迈加拉、比雷埃夫斯、科林斯，这些都是环绕雅典的城市，你在那里感受到的是那种至今游客仍然能感受到或梦想感受到的战栗，因为他们现在感受不到了，因为太多的游客往往只去古董（你知道的）古代遗址。但这种梦想是偶然 stumbled upon（偶遇）某座古老城市的浩瀚与孤独，并感到脊背发凉。很显然，苏尔皮库斯所表达的几乎就是同样的情绪，你从“曾经伟大的事物已不再伟大”的思考中获得一种战栗感。
longer so. So it's sort of Ozymandias, isn't it? The traveller in the desert sees the statue and it makes him think about the passing of time and the contours of history and all these kinds of things. But interestingly, there is also a kind of counter view that actually what you want when you say you go to Greece is you don't just want ruins. You want to experience, say, Athens or Sparta as they were in their heyday. So when Cicero goes, and Athens really, Athens, I suppose, is what Rome is to, well, it's a cross between what Rome was to Milords in the days of the Grand Tour and perhaps what Oxford is to Rhodes scholars. So it's a place that is the kind of the home of history, the home of art, but it's also a kind of a finishing school with great ancient monuments all around where you can feel yourself. So Cicero says that,
所以这有点像奥齐曼迪亚斯，不是吗？沙漠中的旅行者看到了雕像，这让他思考时间的流逝、历史的轮廓以及所有这类事情。但有趣的是，也有另一种相反的观点，即当你去希腊时，你想要的其实不仅仅是废墟。你希望体验雅典或斯巴达在全盛时期的样子。所以当西塞罗去的时候，雅典真的，雅典，我想，之于罗马，就相当于，嗯，这介于罗马之于壮游时代的贵族老爷们之间，以及牛津大学之于罗德学者之间。所以这是一个既是历史之家、艺术之家，同时也是一个精修学校的地方，周围环绕着伟大的古代纪念碑，在那里你可以感受到自己……所以西塞罗说，
he describes the sites to be seen in Athens, the tomb of Pericles, the walkway where Demosthenes practiced his oratory. And he says that such things are endless in the city. For wherever we walk, we plant our footsteps on some piece of history. But by the time that the greatest tourist in Roman history, who is the Emperor Hadrian, who goes all over the Roman world. But Greece is really his love, and he goes there again and again and again. By the time he goes to Athens, he wants more than this sense of faded glories. And so what Hadrian can do because he's emperor is basically restore Athens to its former primacy. So he develops Athens on a massive scale. He brings in infrastructure. It's Hadrian who finishes off this temple to Zeus that Sulla had kind of nicked the columns from. And he enshrines Athens at the head of a kind of great confederation of Greek cities. basically trying to take Athens back to the heyday of the 5th century BC when all this tribute was coming in from Greek cities with which they built the Parthenon. So that's what he's trying to do.
他描述了在雅典可以看到的遗址，伯里克利的陵墓，德摩斯梯尼练习演说的步道。他说这样的事物在城里层出不穷。因为无论我们走到哪里，我们的脚步都踏在某些历史的片段上。但到了罗马历史最伟大的游客——也就是皇帝哈德良——游历整个罗马世界的时候。但希腊确实是他的挚爱，他一次又一次地去那里。当他去雅典时，他想要的不仅仅是这种昔日辉煌的感觉。所以哈德良能做到的是，因为他是皇帝，他基本上将雅典恢复到了它先前的首要地位。所以他大规模地开发雅典。他引进了基础设施。正是哈德良完成了苏拉从上面剥离了柱子的这座宙斯神庙。他将雅典置于一个由希腊城市组成的宏伟联盟之首，基本上是试图将雅典带回公元前5世纪的全盛时期，当时所有的税收都来自希腊城市，他们用这些税收建造了帕台农神庙。所以这就是他试图做的事情。
He's trying to get Athens back to the 5th century so that then he can experience that kind of glory. And the other kind of intriguing city try and and resurrect try and kind of resurrect history is sparta because sparta famously there isn't much to see um so when when paulus goes to sparta livy says there isn't much you know there wasn't much to see there i can vouch for that i went to sparta last year tom there wasn't much to see i know and i directed you to a place full of homeless people didn't i yeah well you directed me to a temple where the guidebook then said, under no circumstances go to this temple. Sorry about that.
他试图让雅典回到5世纪，这样他就能体验那种辉煌。另一个试图去重现、试图去复活历史的引人入胜的城市是斯巴达，因为斯巴达众所周知，没有什么可看的。所以当保卢斯去斯巴达时，李维说没有多少东西可看，你知道，那里没有多少东西可看。我可以担保这一点，我去年去了斯巴达，汤姆，那里真的没多少东西可看。我懂的，我把你指引到一个到处都是无家可归之人的地方去了，不是吗？对，你把我指引到了一座神庙，那里的旅游指南当时说，无论在什么情况下都不要去这座神庙。真是不好意思。
So Livy says that Paulus goes to Sparta not because there was anything to see, but because he wanted to admire the kind of traditional Spartan way of life. You know, the girls wrestling, boys being whipped brutally. I would have loved to have seen all that. I was very disappointed there was none of that going on. Right. I think, you know, secretly people, I think all tourists would quite like to see that.
所以李维说，保卢斯去斯巴达不是因为有什么好看的，而是因为他想欣赏那种传统的斯巴达生活方式。你知道的，女孩们在摔跤，男孩们被残酷地鞭打。我本很想看到所有这些。我感到非常失望，因为这些都没有发生。没错。我想，你知道，暗地里人们，我想所有的游客其实都挺想看到这一幕的。
And Paris is disappointed because by this point, it's not happening. Right. You know, Sparta is just like anywhere else. And so over the course of the first century AD, you're palpably starting to get this sense in Sparta that Roman tourists are turning up and they're disappointed by what they're finding. And by the time that Hadrian is emperor, he turns up and there's wrestling. Girls are wrestling.
而帕里斯感到失望，因为到了这个时候，这一切已经没有了。对，你知道的，斯巴达就像其他地方一样。所以在公元一世纪的进程中，你明显开始在斯巴达感受到这样一种感觉：罗马游客赶到这里，却对他们所发现的景象感到失望。等到哈德良当皇帝时，他来了，这里有了摔跤。女孩们在摔跤。
Boys are being kind of whipped for the entertainment of watching tourists. You know, it's wrestling. Girls are wrestling. Boys are being kind of whipped for the entertainment of watching tourists. You know, it's all. And Hadrian likewise kind of gives money to the Spartans so that they can kind of reinstitute. You know, they could they can have a kind of sense of their old primacy. And I think that's a that's a very, very I suppose it would be like, you know, Bill Gates turning up in Stratford, say, and saying, well, I'm going to pull everything down and rebuild it in a Tudor fashion or something like that. But in a way, Tom, it's exactly the same as the thing we talked about in, I think, the very first episode. No, the second episode, sorry, the Victorian tourism. When we were talking about when people went to Italy on kind of, you know, the sort of early
男孩们为了观光游客的娱乐而被某种程度上鞭打。你知道，这就是全部。女孩们在摔跤。男孩们为了观光游客的娱乐而被某种程度上鞭打。你知道，就是这样。哈德良同样给斯巴达人钱，这样他们就可以某种程度上重塑。你知道，他们可以拥有一种他们过去首要地位的感觉。我认为这非常非常……我想这就像，你知道，比尔·盖茨出现在斯特拉特福，然后说，好吧，我要把所有东西都拆掉，然后以都铎风格重建或者类似的东西。但从某种程度上说，汤姆，这和我们在第一集，不，第二集里讨论过的事情完全一样，抱歉，维多利亚时代的旅游业。当时我们谈到人们去意大利进行那种，你知道的，早期
Victorian package tour type things. They wanted to see Italians making pasta in the old fashioned way rather than with the new, you know, and the way in which actually that this still happens, right? No matter where it is, they specialize in leather and lace kind of old fashioned artisan products that clearly are probably being shipped in by someplace from some factory in China. But what you want to see is you want to see old women, you know, doing the lace in the way that they've done for generations. I mean, that's...
维多利亚时代的团队游之类的事情。他们想看意大利人以老式的方式制作面食，而不是用那种新的方式，而且事实上这种情况仍然在发生，对吧？不管在哪里，他们都专门生产皮具和蕾丝那种老式的传统手工艺品，这些产品显然可能是从中国某个地方的工厂运来的。但你想看的是，你想看到老妇人们，你知道，用她们世世代代采用的方式制作蕾丝。我的意思是，那是……
That is pretty much it. Yeah. But presumably Hadrian is about the... Would I be right in thinking that this is about the peak, as it were, of Roman tourism? Because obviously after Hadrian, you know, we've got the crisis coming of the third century. You've got the sort of the contraction of the empire, the economic attraction, plagues, and so on. So presumably the whole, as it were, the tourist industry,
差不多就是这样。是的。不过想必哈德里安时期大约是……我这样认为对吗，这大约是罗马旅游业的鼎盛时期？因为很显然，在哈德里安之后，你知道的，我们迎来了公元三世纪的危机。你会看到帝国的某种收缩、经济萎缩、瘟疫等等。所以想必，整个旅游业——
if that's not a completely anachronistic way of talking about it, begins to implode from that point onwards. Yes, I think so. And also, of course, with the coming of Christianity, that shared classical culture starts to fade um yeah but i you know i think while it lasts is it a tourist i suppose you could i mean without too much risk of anachronism i think you could definitely say that um the the you know the relationship of the roman elites to the Greek world in particular, it does have kind of echoes of very, very high-end contemporary tourism, perhaps.
如果用这种方式来谈论它并非完全不符合时代的话——从那个时间点开始逐渐走向瓦解。是的，我想是的。而且当然，随着基督教的到来，那种共享的古典文化开始消逝。嗯，但我知道，我认为只要它存在，它算是一种旅游吗？我想你可以——我的意思是，在不太可能造成时代错乱的风险下，我认为你绝对可以说，嗯，罗马精英与希腊世界（尤其是希腊世界）的关系，确实在某种程度上带有一点非常非常高端的现代旅游的影子，也许吧。
I think it's slightly more ambiguous with places beyond the Greek world. So, for instance, Augustus, his grandson and adopted son, Gaius, he is in the East and he has to pass through Judea. And Suetonius tells us that Augustus wrote to him approvingly because while Gaius was traveling through Judea, he had not gone and seen Jerusalem. So the implication of that is firstly that Jerusalem was a kind of tourist attraction for Romans. Yeah, that you could have stopped off and seen it. Yeah, you would go and look at the temple, Herod's Great Temple, which was absolutely a kind of tourist attraction, but also that you're to be admired for not doing that, for being devoted
我认为对于希腊世界以外的地方，情况就有点含糊了。举个例子，奥古斯都的孙子兼养子盖乌斯，他在东方，必须穿过犹太地。苏维托尼乌斯告诉我们，奥古斯都写信对表示赞许，因为盖乌斯在穿过犹太地时，没有去参观耶路撒冷。所以这暗示了首先耶路撒冷对罗马人来说是一种旅游景点。是的，你可以中途停留并去参观它。是的，你会去看那座神殿，希罗德大帝的神殿，这绝对是一种旅游景点，但同时也意味着你因为没有那样做、因为忠于——
to duty. I think also, of course, the other land that is absolutely stuffed full of tourist attractions is Egypt. But for the very high end traveler, Egypt is problematic because it's the private property of Caesar. And from Augustus onwards, senators are not allowed to travel to Egypt. So even Germanicus, who is in the reign of Tiberius, an absolute war hero, almost projected to succeed Tiberius as emperor, he goes to Alexandria to basically see the sites and gets into all kinds of trouble. But that doesn't stop people below the rank of senator from going to Egypt. And we have this brilliant, brilliant record of exactly how many Romans are going to Egypt in the form of these two great statues of the pharaoh Amenhotep III, who's the father of
职责而受到赞赏。我想当然，另一片绝对塞满旅游景点的土地是埃及。但对于极其高端的旅行者来说，埃及是个棘手的地方，因为它是凯撒的私产。从奥古斯都开始，元老院议员是不被允许前往埃及的。因此，甚至连日耳曼尼库斯——他在提比略统治时期是一位绝对的战争英雄，几乎被预定为继承提比略的皇帝——他前往亚历山大基本上只是为了参观名胜，结果惹上了各种麻烦。但这并没有阻止元老院议员级别以下的人前往埃及。我们有着非常非常出色的记录，记录了到底有多少罗马人前往埃及，其形式就是法老阿蒙霍特普三世的两座巨大雕像，他是——的父亲
Akhenaten. And they were erected outside this huge funerary temple at Thebes, so Luxor, on the West Bank, so kind of in front of the road that leads to the Valley of the Kings. But by the time that Roman tourists are going there, they've completely forgotten who these two great statues are, these two colossi, as they call them. And they think that it's a hero called Memnon, who they believed had been the king of Ethiopia, who'd come to the Trojan War. He was the son of the Dawn. He died in the Trojan War, killed by Achilles. And then the Dawn had gone to Zeus and had begged for Memnon to be brought back to life. And so Zeus allowed him to become an immortal. And there was a weird kind of atmospheric freakish quality
阿肯那顿。它们竖立在底比斯（也就是卢克索）西岸这座巨大的陵庙外面，大致就在通往帝王谷的道路前方。但当罗马游客去那里时，他们已经完全忘记这两尊巨大的雕像是谁了，也就是他们所称的两座巨像。他们认为这是一个名叫门农的英雄，他们相信他是埃塞俄比亚国王，曾参加特洛伊战争。他是黎明女神的儿子。他在特洛伊战争中阵亡，被阿喀琉斯杀死。然后黎明女神去找宙斯，恳求让门农复活。于是宙斯允许他成为一个不朽的神。而且有一种奇怪的、类似大气奇观的特性——
to the base of one of these statues, which was that very often at dawn, when the sun first came up, the base of the statue would sing. Well, it wouldn't exactly sing. We're told that it sounds like a lyre being played with a broken string so there must have been some crack that the wind was going through or something or there's kind of i think there's moisture perhaps in a crack and as
在其中一座雕像的底座上，那就是通常在破晓时分，当太阳初升时，雕像的底座会唱歌。嗯，它其实不算是唱歌。我们被告知，听起来就像是一把断了弦的竖琴在弹奏，所以一定有什么裂缝让风吹过，或者某种——我想可能裂缝里有水分，随着——
the sun comes up and it dries it and it makes it produces the sound but this this basically i mean maybe even more than the pyramids is what people in Egypt want to see. And so they go to these statues and they graffiti it. So they pay money to the priests who then chisel kind of, you know, names all over the colossi of Memeron, as they're called. And so it's an incredible, you know, it's a fabulous record of just how many people are going there. So for instance, there's a guy called Swadius, who is also attested in Tacitus. He gets involved in the civil wars of AD 69, the year of
太阳升起并使其变干，它就会发出声音。但基本上——我的意思是，这甚至可能比金字塔还要吸引埃及游客。所以他们前往这些雕像并在上面乱涂乱画。因此他们付钱给祭司，祭司就会把各种名字凿在被称为门农巨像的雕像各处。所以这是一份令人难以置信的、极好的记录，记录了究竟有多少人在那里。例如，有一个叫斯瓦迪乌斯的人，他在塔西陀的著作中也有记载。他卷入了公元69年四帝内战。他参与为奥托作战。然后他被维斯帕西安派去整顿庞贝。所以他的告示和铭文遍布庞贝。然后他的名字出现在门农的雕像上，这太绝了。但门农雕像上最著名的铭文是由一位名叫朱莉娅·巴尔比拉的女性刻写的，她是一位杰出的诗人，也是一位生活在雅典的非常非常富有的国王孙子的姐姐。她进行了可能是有史以来最著名的罗马埃及之旅，这次旅行同样也是哈德里安带队的。哈德里安前往亚历山大。他乘船顺尼罗河而下。他的妻子萨比娜也同行，而朱莉娅·巴尔比拉作为萨比娜的同伴也在场。他们抵达门农雕像前。他们在黎明时分一起去等待雕像唱歌。
the four emperors. He's involved fighting for Otho. And then he gets sent by Vespasian to sort out Pompeii. And so his kind of posters and inscriptions are all over Pompeii. And then his name pops up on the statue of Memnon, which is brilliant. But the most famous inscriptions on the statue of Memnon are inscribed by a woman called Julia Balbila, who is a distinguished poet, the sister of a very, very wealthy grandson of a king who lived in Athens. And she goes on possibly the most famous Roman tour of Egypt of the lot, which again is Hadrian. Hadrian travels to Alexandria. He sails down the Nile. He's with his wife, Sabina, and Julia Balbila is there as Sabina's companion. And they arrive at the statues of Memnon. They all go and dawn to wait for the statues to sing.
它们没有唱歌。哈德里安就先走了。但朱莉娅和萨比娜第二天又去了，听到了它们唱歌。她们一次又一次地回去，因为她们对这种现象太着迷了。朱莉娅将她的四首诗刻在了门农雕像的腿上，直到今天它们仍然留在那儿。哦，太棒了。听起来太惊人了。拜伦爵士曾在阿提卡苏尼恩的海神庙上刻下自己的名字，这可是出了名的。而几个世纪前的朱莉娅·巴尔比拉基本上在做同样的事情。所以我想你确实会有一种——也许，你知道的——某种历史镜像的感觉。
They don't sing. Hadrian kind of goes off. But Julia and Sabina go back the next day and hear them sing. And they go back again and again and again, because they're so fascinated by the phenomenon. And Julia has four of her poems inscribed on the leg of the statue of Memnon, and they're there to this day. Oh, wonderful. That sounds amazing. Byron notoriously chisels his name on the Temple of Poseidon at Suneon in Attica. Julia Balbila, centuries and centuries before, is basically doing the same thing. And so I think you do have this sense of perhaps, you know, kind of mirrors being held up.
不幸的是，汤姆，这给了那些在古代古迹上乱涂乱画的人——现在主要是青少年——以合法性，而他们总是这样做。我想你必须得是一个高端的雅典诗人或是一位贵族。是的，才能逃脱惩罚。真的才能逃脱惩罚。真的才能逃脱惩罚。我是这么想的。
Yeah. Unfortunately, Tom, that gives legitimacy to all those people who scrawl their names, teenagers now, on ancient monuments, which they invariably do. I think you've got to be a kind of high-end Athenian poet or a lord. Yeah, to get away with it. Really to get away with it. Really to get away with it. I think.
还有最后一个问题，我想，主要是关于我的网络。我刚收到一条消息说我的网络连接不稳定。哦，不。所以听众们听到这个会担心的，因为他们担心这个播客的未来。我可以向你们保证，我代表着稳定，我将确保恢复稳定，这也是我自这个播客开播以来一直倡导的。现在，汤姆，关于你提到的基督教的到来。很显然，你知道的，对古典遗产的追求
And one last question, I think, is among other things, my internet. I've just had a message saying my internet connection is unstable. Oh, no. So listeners will be worried to hear that because they're worried about the future of the podcast. I can assure you I stand for stability and I will ensure the restoration of stability, something I've advocated since the very beginning of this podcast. Now, Tom, it's about, you mentioned the coming of Christianity. And obviously, you know, the search for the classical heritage
某种程度上处于暂停状态，可以说是这样。但它被别的东西取代了，那就是朝圣。人们想要去耶路撒冷，人们想要去罗马。所以我们在本周一开始的时候谈到了阿尔弗雷德大帝小时候去罗马的事，不是吗，进行朝圣。你认为把这些称为度假有多大合理性？因为那里显然有支持它的基础设施，而且确实有着与我们现代度假相同的旅行感、期待感、兴奋感、
kind of goes into abeyance, as it were. But it's replaced with something else, which is pilgrimages. So people wanting to go to Jerusalem, people wanting to go to Rome. So we talked at the very beginning of this week about Alfred the Great as a little boy going to Rome, didn't we, on a pilgrimage. How much do you think it's reasonable to talk about those in terms of holidays? Because there clearly was an infrastructure to support it, and there's the same sense of travel, of anticipation, of excitement,
快乐感和升华感。嗯，我们讨论过这个。我的意思是，我们非常简短地触及过这个话题，你只需要看看《坎特伯雷故事集》就会发现，快乐绝对是其中的一部分。我的意思是，这就是人们这样做的原因。但你不应该过分强调这一点，因为对于早期中世纪的人们来说，确实非常艰难。我的意思是，非常残酷。危险是巨大的。特别是如果你在中世纪旅行，尤其是当耶路撒冷处于穆斯林统治之下时，前往耶路撒冷——如果你是一个基督徒，那是顶级朝圣目的地——是非常非常危险的。
of fun, of uplift that we get with modern holidays. Well, we talked about this. I mean, we kind of touched on it very briefly that you only have to look at the Canterbury Tales to see that fun was absolutely a part of it. I mean, that's why people were doing it. But you shouldn't overemphasize that because certainly for people in the early Middle Ages, it was really tough. I mean, it was really brutal. The dangers were enormous. And particularly if you were traveling throughout the Middle Ages, particularly when Jerusalem was under Muslim rule, to travel to Jerusalem, which is top pilgrimage destination if you're a Christian, was very, very dangerous.
对于去朝觐的穆斯林来说也是如此。同样，也有一些机会。你暂时脱离了正常的生活环境。所以在某种意义上，这确实有点像去度假。但我的意思是，除非过程艰辛，否则它就不算是真正的朝圣。而且我认为它们确实很艰辛。话虽如此，再次回到罗马时期，即公元四世纪，当时也许基础设施、人们前往各个古典遗址游玩的集体记忆仍然是一种活生生的事物。前往巴勒斯坦、前往圣地的那些高端朝圣者在四世纪时——其中最著名的是海伦娜，
And likewise for Muslims traveling, doing the Hajj. Again, there are opportunities. You're getting out of your normal situation. So there are, in that sense, kind of echoes of going on holiday. But I mean, it wasn't really a pilgrimage unless it was tough. And I think they were tough. But having said that, again, going back to the Roman period, the fourth century, when perhaps the infrastructure, the infrastructure, the folk memories of people going on trips around the classical sites was still a kind of living thing. High-end pilgrims going to Palestine, going to the Holy Land in the fourth century, of whom the most famous is Helena,
君士坦丁的母亲。当他们到达那里时，这与去雅典或埃及不同，因为通常你在寻找并不存在的东西。众所周知，海伦娜出现在耶路撒冷。她想看耶稣死的地方，也就是他的墓。她想看到真十字架。它并不在那里。于是她开始进行考古发掘。瞧，它们就在那儿。
the mother of Constantine. When they get there, it's different to going to Athens or Egypt because often you're looking for things that aren't there. So famously, Helena turns up in Jerusalem. She wants to see the place where Jesus died, his tomb. She wants to see the true cross. It's not there. And so she starts excavating. And whoa, there they are.
就在那儿。她找到了真十字架。谁会想到呢？多么惊人的巧合啊。是的。所以这就是为什么她是考古学家的主保圣人。在四世纪的过程中，前往巴勒斯坦的朝圣者，基本上与当地人联手，构建了一种旅游行程。所以他们会说，你知道的，这座山是当年大卫做那件事的地方。这栋房子是彼得住过的地方。这个湖是耶稣在上面行走的地方，
There it is. She finds the true cross. Who would have thought that? What an extraordinary coincidence. Yeah. So that's why she's the patron saint of archaeologists. course of the fourth century, pilgrims who are going to Palestine, basically in liaison with the locals, are constructing a kind of tourist itinerary. So they're saying, you know, this hill is where David did that. This house is where Peter lived. This lake is where Jesus walked on the
诸如此类。他们构建了一种至今仍然存在的旅游地形学。因此，基本上当旅游团前往以色列并参观圣经遗址时，十有八九他们参观的圣经遗址是在四世纪由非常相似的罗马旅游团人为制造出来的圣经遗址。所以我认为这是一种迷人的延续性。嗯，这是一个很好的收尾方式，因为我的意思是，本周的伟大主题之一就是延续性，不是吗？我的意思是，这是历史的普遍主题之一，但对于假期和旅游业来说，非常有趣的是，大旅行家（Grand Tourists）所做的、托马斯·库克先驱们所做的、20世纪50年代第一批乘坐地平线航班的人所做的，或者甚至是普林尼和他那座听起来坦白说令人愉悦的别墅，究竟有多少相似之处。
water, whatever. They're kind of constructing a tourist topography that is still there to this day. So that basically when tour parties go to Israel and visit the biblical sites, as likely as not, they're visiting biblical sites that were manufactured as biblical sites in the fourth century by very similar Roman tour parties. And so I think that is a kind of fascinating continuity. Well, that's a lovely way to end because I mean, one of the great themes of this week has been continuity, hasn't it? I mean, it's one of the themes of history generally, but it's really interesting with holidays and with tourism, how many things that the Grand Tourists did, that the Thomas Cook pioneers did, that the first people on the Horizon flights in the 1950s, or indeed Pliny and his frankly delightful sounding villa.
它们是如此具有辨识度，对吧？汤姆，我听说你不久就要去度假了，对吗？你自己有一个希腊假期。嗯，要到十月份，因为我不想在还没写完书就把假期定下来，所以我把时间尽量往后推了，但是是的，非常期待。我需要它。太令人兴奋了。所以汤姆，现在可以自由去规划他的假期了。我呢，要去开始建立稳定机构了——显然我一向关注互联网的稳定，
They're so recognisable, aren't they? And Tom, you've got a holiday coming up, I believe, haven't you? You've got a Greek holiday of your own. Well, not till October because I didn't want to book it and still have not finished my book so i left it as late as possible but yeah very much looking forward to it i need it very exciting so tom uh can is now free to go and plan his holiday um i am going to go and begin the institution of the of stability um which i'm obviously all about internet stability
就我而言，然后我会转向王国的政治和文化稳定，这是我一直在本周这个播客上倡导的。汤姆，我们接下来有什么节目？我们将通过电影这种媒介来讲述法国历史。我们有简·格雷夫人。我们有中国与第二次世界大战。我们有各种各样的好东西。各种各样的精彩内容。
in my case and then i'll move on to the political and cultural stability of the realm, something I always advocate for on this podcast. And Tom, what have we got coming up? We've got French history told through the medium of film. We've got Lady Jane Grey. We've got China and the Second World War. We've got all kinds of goodies. All kinds of treats.
其实这比去度假还要好，对吧？听这个播客。它本身就是一个假期。它令人精神振奋，而且其实这比去度假还要好，不是吗？听听这个，它本身就是一个假期，它令人精神振奋，而且也极其性感，我认为这正是人们在假期中所寻找的，天哪，绝对是。你难道不相信人们会寻找这个吗？还是说你不敢相信我对这个播客有这种看法？我有点不敢相信你竟然认为这个播客很性感，除了“爱情岛”鸽子（注：指某节目相关梗）这个微乎其微的例外。我只是在反映公众告诉我的情况。这是一个非常非常激动人心的想法，我认为我们可以借此说再见了。
It's actually better than going on holiday, isn't it? Listen to this podcast. It's a holiday in itself. It's uplifting, and it's actually better than going on holiday isn't it listen to this it's a holiday in itself it's uplifting and it's also enormously sexy which is i think what people look for um in a holiday goodness definitely are you incredulous that people look for that or you're incredulous that i think that about this podcast i'm slightly incredulous that you think this podcast is sexy with the possible exception of love island pigeons. I'm reflecting what the public tell me. That is a very, very exciting thought and one on which I think we should say goodbye.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家精选节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishist 注册。The Rest Is Entertainment 是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们为娱乐行业拉开帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishist The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家番外、提前解锁、纯净无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishist... 《娱乐的余烬》为您每周提供娱乐新闻、精彩评论和一点八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，带您了解其运作机制。我们的会员俱乐部刚刚上线。如果您想要无广告收听、独家番外节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。